there we go hi everybody so nice to see
you all today welcome to the posit
Enterprise Community Meetup this is our
last Meetup of the year and I don't know
how the year went by so fast I'm Rachel
and I lead our customer Community here
at posit
welcome to the Meetup this is a friendly
and open environment for teams to share
use cases teach lessons learned and just
meet each other and ask questions
if you've joined us here at the Meetup
before maybe put a two into the YouTube
chat if this is your first time joining
special welcome to you put a one in the
chat
for those who have here before I
encourage you to help welcome everybody
in
uh over in in the YouTube chat as well
together we're all dedicated to making
this space inclusive and open for
everyone no matter your experience
history or background
during the event we will certainly have
time for Q a
so you're able to ask questions on
YouTube live
and also anonymously through slido which
I'll share on the screen here in just a
second
there we go so you can use that slido
link there to ask questions anonymously
but also for some of the questions that
we'll have during the presentation
I actually did just put a poll over
there to start with and just wanted to
ask everybody do you deploy your own
apis today to just get a feel for where
everybody's at
so if you want to jump over there to the
slido it's just pause it POS dot i t
slash Meetup Dash question and our team
can put in the chat too
I know Davis our presenter has a few
questions for you that will show through
slido as well to address one of the
popular
up front yes the recording will be
available and it will actually be ready
as the presentation ends the exact same
YouTube link
but with all of that said thank you so
much for joining us here today I am so
excited to have Davis derodes here
director of data science at the Luma
project at Luma whose work focuses on
the intersection of human-centric
content and sales uh Davis's focus is
our full stack data science causal
inference data quality explainability
and r
and Davis I will pull you up here onto
our virtual stage
thank you so much for joining us
thanks for having me Rachel I really
appreciate it also thanks everyone
commenting the chat and deciding to come
here I know holiday times are around and
things are hectic so it means a lot to
come and have some fun together
um also I heard this last one of the
year so hopefully uh we got on a high
note
um so I'll just Dive Right In again I'm
Dave steroes I'm the director of data
science here at Luma I am a small data
science team leader so it's just me a
senior day scientist and a senior
analytics engineer it's a pretty small
team so if there are questions later or
discussion topics later for small team
data science I'm all game for that too
but at first we're going to discuss uh
the main topic at hand which is uh apis
uh so the title I came up with this for
this talk is why I stopped worrying and
learn to love the API uh which for those
who don't know is a joke or pun from uh
the Peter Sellers Stanley Kubrick film
uh Dr Strangelove or how I learned to
stop worrying and love the bomb
again I always love a good pun and good
word play uh however the the real point
I was trying to get at was
uh apis are the bomb they're great
they're fantastic
in my data science journey I definitely
started more in the stats kind of
experimentation realm it kind of moved
and became more data engineering back
and focus uh and definitely my earlier
data science experiences apis were
always a hassle someone's like oh the
data's in the API I was like oh please
no uh it was always annoying thing to
query and to get the data from and to
structure it properly it was just really
annoying the tools were really annoying
I was using the time as well
um and also the other side of coin too
is deploying apis
I've always found super annoying as well
with Docker and all the headache around
that and normally even in my classes we
wouldn't even deploy the API someplace
it would just be creating the API and
just like letting it host locally
um so again I uh I'm very much uh now a
big fan of apis uh especially my current
work at Luma I feel like I use them all
the time and I just want everyone to
kind of feel the joy especially if
you're on the more statsy side of data
science uh with apis
um
so
let's Dive Right In before I kind of go
into the main kind of elements of this
talk I do want to give some background
of kind of what we do at Luma uh so Luma
is a retail media startup located in
Durham North Carolina which is where I'm
at
and we seek to be the leader in
human-centric point decision content
distribution what that looks like today
is if you can see in the kind of image
in the back it's our product called Loop
which is a network of tablets and
grocery retailers so basically tablets
you know in your local brand Harris
Teeter for example in your local grocery
store playing content related to the
products that are on the Shelf so uh
here you can see that this tablet is
mounted on a beer cooler and it's
playing films about the beers that are
in that cooler and those films are very
human-centric right so they're about the
people who made the beer you know the
stories behind the products and the
people who enjoy them
um so that is what Luma is and the data
science team is really trying to
optimized Loop and then also uh kind of
evaluate how efficacious it is is that a
word hope it is
um so with that that's the background
Luma I have a couple examples from Luma
I have a couple examples not from Luma
but I just want to give that background
just for kind of what I'm working on
currently and also uh some of the
examples that come later
now I know we have a couple polls going
the first kind of question I want to ask
to folks is how annoying is it to pull
and store data from apis so if someone's
like hey got this data for you it's in
this API and you need to have it in
consistently in your data ecosystem how
annoying from like a scale one to five
I'm not sure what the metrics we created
were but uh do you find that
foreign
people answer the last question that I
put up first so I'll wait till I see at
least 20 in here now but I just put that
um
link onto the chat here too it looks
like we're seeing
kind of annoying is starting to to win
here that would have been my guess kind
of annoying
of the worst is a pretty strong
sentiment
there is another verse that just came in
too
let's see I hope everybody can see these
answers too if not I'll make them sure
this might be my wife
okay kind of annoying is is still taking
the lead 56 of people have said kind of
annoying all right fantastic great that
that that's also great to hear I would
personally answer that question
someplace between Pleasant and
delightful so hopefully the stuff I'm
going to discuss a layer will hopefully
maybe shine some light into maybe a poor
a more positive experience possibly and
the second question I want to add to ask
too which given by that response I'm
assuming this one and the first question
that Rachel asks is uh how easy is it to
create and deploy an API
which I believe Richard probably around
the first question most folks do not
deploy an API currently is that correct
yes so the the first question
um I asked in the intro yes a lot of
people haven't yet deployed an API
but I'm seeing right now for how easy is
it to create and deploy uh we're going
from uh the worst now we're jumping over
to no opinion 50 it's changing very
quickly here
one more second here
okay we're we're topping out at 50 for
the no opinion others uh skewing towards
other worst are kind of annoying
that is great to hear so hopefully uh
throughout this talk this will be a
hopefully useful helpful talk
um to hopefully move you at least out of
Ugg and kind of annoying to either no
opinion or maybe even Pleasant uh for
creating deploying apis with posit
connect I'm a delightful I probably
create too many apis now uh if you ask
my team uh it's apis and slack Bots are
the two things
um
folks folks tell me I make too much of
uh so our agenda today for the rest of
the talk are I divided into three
sections first is querying external apis
so just basic calling rest apis uh best
practices for me at least for exploring
formatting and organizing those queries
and also productionizing those
extractions to put it into your data
environment using posit connect and also
a really great workflow that leverages
the exploration the formatting you did
in the first step
the second section is going to be on
functional API request generation with r
basically a bunch of fun use cases for
if there's folks in your company doing
things manually in other systems that
you know there's an API and you see the
right query to you know create the thing
they're doing and automate that you can
do that with posit connect and I'm sure
you guys a really cool example with
something that we call score at Luma
regarding uh evaluating the films that
we create
uh with type form and also integrates
with slack as well so if you're
interested in slack interest in type
form hopefully you'll see how this
really cool thing we built
um and hopefully uh it will inspire some
uh your own projects and the last thing
is creating deploying apis with positive
connect just that last question we just
asked you guys right of um both sharing
data externally a great use case for
apis if you have technical external
stakeholders there's probably no better
way to share data than with an API and
then also ingesting data so if you need
to bring in data from folks uh apis are
also a great way to do that well
especially with external technical
stakeholders and also even sharing
Justin Davis technical internal
stakeholders so if you have an
engineering team and you need to send
data over to them to populate in a front
end an API is a great it's probably the
preferred way to do it honestly
um
so let's talk in that first one though
before we get too far ahead I just with
the creating external apis
uh and just a quick background too just
for folks who are really unfamiliar with
apis which it didn't seem too many folks
didn't know what an API was but
um there's a great article that uh I've
kind of cited here below uh regarding
kind of the framework of what is an API
uh which a great metaphor I've heard is
API is a waiter so you the requester are
like the customer at the restaurant if
you will uh and then the API is the
waiter and the recipient is the kitchen
right so you could be like like a ham
sandwich right the API takes that to the
recipient and then gives brings you back
hopefully a ham sandwich or tells you
hey we're out of ham or you ask for ham
the wrong way or something along those
lines
um
so that's kind of a really great
metaphor I like the thing is too is that
things on your side can change so for
example uh your back end can change for
example like you create a new table but
as long as you're matching the same
schema or matching the API format the
same way if you're the recipient for
example uh it's all good so the API is a
really great middle point to translate
the needs of your requesters and what
you have on your back end
and a joke I like to make too is that
also occasionally
um you can have a mean recipient right
like Gordon Ramsay uh who tells you you
don't have permission and you're you're
unauthorized
um
keeping it light guys last one of the
year
uh so I'm gonna do a quick uh demo of um
of kind of my workflow personally and I
think it's a really great workflow for
exploring API requests
um so I'm gonna share my screen
oops wrong share
I'll pull it over in just a second yeah
it would have been all five I didn't
touch anything uh hopefully all y'all
can see my uh uh my uh our terminal
currently
um so first thing I'm going to do is
Library titaniverse of course as all
great our scripts start with
um and there's a link I would love uh
for you all to see and GitHub regarding
just like a list of just free apis out
there it's a really fun list of just
free data out there that you can um that
you can pull from the API uh these
various apis one I did find on that list
uh was this Aviation API I know nothing
about planes maybe this is a really
terrible example but it is completely
free it's also uh there's no Gordon
Ramsay No One's Gonna tell you're not
authenticated so it's a public
completely public API for you to get
data regarding airports
um so uh normally when you go to an API
you'll see some amount of documentation
and this for me is very aware on the
mill for API documentation there's also
a lot of standard like wrappers around
apis that just Auto generate the
documentation and this is one of the
ones I've seen pretty frequently
um
text is a bit fuzzy okay plus plus
better
um so you can see here uh in this API
true okay well hopefully it's better
um I'll zoom in on the r but basically
you'll see these different uh URL
requests for the function so you see
right here right this is a get request
for all the charts for a specific
airport and you can get the server URL
here so this is basically you're gonna
be your the main thing you want to
basically query the API
bring your response from the API so
we're going to take this right we're
going to bring it back to our API call
here we can just put in here
and then we need to specify which uh
airport we want to do so here you see
the query parameters and with a standard
just like uh rest API
fantastic uh the standard rest API
you're just going to add a question mark
the parameter name
and then equal sign and then whatever
you want to put in so as I mentioned
before I'm in the Raleigh Durham area so
I picked our local airport RDU
and then when you run this
gonna do you're gonna get that and the
main package we're going to be
leveraging for running API requests uh
is this HTTR package here and when you
get back it's going to be a lot of
gobbledygook like this is not very
helpful it's a lot of the headers you
know whether the response is 200 which
means it was accepted if you get a 403
Gordon Ramsay that means it was
forbidden and you're not authenticated
properly if it's a 404 that means it was
not responsive which is really weird so
hopefully you get 200s but this isn't
very helpful for us the magic function
you're going to want to use is this HTTR
content
which is going to extract the content
from that uh response you got so now if
I look at the the actual content
okay krdu that's the airport code for
Raleigh
and then we get a beautiful list in
rstudio to explore and for me this is
really great UI in my opinion because
you can just go through here and look
okay this one this is around the right
structure right this is looking good all
right we can do one more step further
which is we can put it in a tabular
format so there's one or two ways to do
this I'll show you guys the first way to
do it which is if everything is really
flat so there's no nested list or
anything uh you can just use map dfr
and just get tabular data from the API
just like that
I'm guessing these are charts these are
PDFs we can pull up I think that's what
this data source is
um but that is one way to do it uh just
right there
so literally uh this is weather so this
is a little bit more complicated one
so if I go to API I think weather was
over here yep so I went over here I get
the server URL here and again they
should be pretty standard in most API
documentation you'll see just bring that
over
from our terminal over here and then it
had the parameter of the airport code
again so I put it here
so I'm gonna get that response
it's going to give me something pretty
gobbledygooky but then I got that
content
and then we have here the same different
data right for a different request so
this is for the airport weather I'm
guessing uh and the one thing I want to
show you here is that these are normally
jsons that are coming back and they can
have nested structures as a lot of jsons
do and you see here the sky conditions
has this nested aspect here so if we do
map dfr it's going to come out weird and
we don't want to do that so another way
to do this and this is the way I do it
with complicated queries is I start by
just making the weather content Temple
you see here it's just going to most
likely be just like a one row one column
list inside of a table
and we're just going to unnest it wider
and we're gonna get you know something
looks pretty normal but we still have
this nested list here in the sky
conditions but as any tidy verse Pro
knows you can just do more per functions
um to get to what you want and now we
have two different rows here one for
each of the different Sky conditions we
had that base uh AGL metric that is and
also the uh category
so yeah so this is really basic how I
personally explore apis in rstudio I
personally think rstudio is a really
great place to explore apis uh if we go
back to the slides please
awesome thanks
um
all right gotta get them to the slide
there we go uh so just to show kind of
comparison like the r Studio experience
I put our experience but really our
studio experience on the left is just so
much better than from the experiences
I've had running in other environments
so for example that's just uh my
terminal uh right you just keep this
long Json you don't know what's why it's
kind of complicated look at versus this
is something you can go through all the
objects and see the structure really
clearly
um so personally I our studio is my
favorite tool for exploring apis
so okay so now you've done your
exploration you know what you want all
right so what's next uh I recommend
structuring your kind of API query so
for when you're just getting data
um in two types of functions so for one
uh query generation so first just a
function to just generate the query that
you're going to want want to run or the
request you're going to want to run uh
just a function up top this is really
helpful too for debugging especially if
you're using non-rest API so for example
our team has an internal uh postgresql
API that sits on top of uh yeah
database it's some type of a graphql API
that's it got my ql's confused graphql
API uh in which case those queries are
much more complicated they're much
longer and it's really nice to be able
to easily just run a query get the run a
function get the query and send it over
to them for them to help me debug
um and also just useful just have it to
put it run in a terminal or send it to
someone else the second type of function
is to format the output for what you
actually want so just actually getting
the weather response uh in this case in
the format that we want so that includes
running the API call extracting the
content and then formatting it using
tidy versus functions
and so if you see the bottom that's an
example and then now with this
functionalize I can run it for any
airport I want for example the Atlanta
airport which is where uh where my
family lives
uh so okay so now you have functions to
get the API request you want great so
what's next next is productionalizing
that and getting it into your data
ecosystem uh so as always our packages
are fantastic so absolutely make a
package including all your functions all
those query and get functions and they
are really great uh make an rmd or
quarto uh with all the basically things
you want to run and ingest I recommend
publishing it on posit connect and
scheduling its Generation
Um and then you can get the email
notifications from positive connect or
you can add a slackbot I love this
slacker package I probably have way too
many slack Bots uh on our team
um but then you need a nice little
message every morning letting you know
that hey the ingestion went through
um
and like you got your data in your
Warehouse properly so this is like a
positive message I get 7 am every
morning and you can also see what the
rmd looks like so for example we're
ingesting all of our film metadata all
of our products all of our Brands
um all of our device slots Etc uh but
also nice thing too is when things go
wrong I can start my morning off with
messaging my Engineers being like hey
did something change in the API that uh
that made things wrong the whole purpose
of an apis that hopefully is static so
especially for public and like really
big companies like hopefully it doesn't
change unless there's a large version
switch however it is really good to know
when apis do change especially
internally so you can surface that to
those teams
great
next is dynamic external API posting
with r
uh in our example I'm going to flag as
our score typeform surveys so the
background for this score time form
project was we need to send surveys
internally asking employees to watch and
review different films uh we needed a UI
to upload a manuals films a click button
kind of solution for folks to generate a
typeform survey and then also set it out
to everyone via slack and they also
ability for users to say I'm busy I
can't review this film right now and
decline it
foreign
majority of this project with just shiny
and apis and polymer apis and also just
type forms slack apis as well
um so we see here there's three main
kind of functions I was discussing so
first uploading a film that was also
used used apis the Vimeo API so all that
involved was having a button
to upload it into shiny because I've
seen that before a button like an action
button basically to then send it to the
Google Cloud bucket and then a call to
the Vimeo API which has functionality to
pull it from the little Cloud bucket uh
and again all that inside shiny so
really press a button upload the film
push it to Vimeo which is really useful
UI the second thing uh cool feature was
sending out surveys
uh so basically okay we have the film in
our environment we have the Vimeo link
for it now we need to send surveys out
to folks so basically pressing a button
it's gonna post uh type form uh like
send an API called to type form and post
a new type form basically
um for all the questions that folks need
to answer regarding the film it's also
going to embed the Vimeo link that we
created in Step One in all the different
slides or write that metadata about
where that survey is located into
bigquery we're a gcp stack too so if
you're using Amazon redshift for example
or other back ends just swap it out with
your Amazon equivalent
and then three uh then per uh we didn't
send a post request to the slack API uh
to send out a message to everyone who we
asked to score the film
the last thing is basically folks being
able to like confirm that like yes I'll
score this or no I'm too busy
um and that is the confirmed survey
acceptance step so first uh we actually
created an API using positive connect
and plumber to take in a response from
the slack app so that when you press yes
on the slack bot it then sends a message
to our polymer API hosted on positive
connect and then that does two things it
writes the response to bigquery and then
notifies the score back in slack that it
was accepted or declined
that all uses an API
so I want to show you guys first uh
we're gonna skip the first one because
it's pretty boring and more about Vimeo
but the second one I want to show y'all
which is sending out the surveys using
uh our tool
um
so I just want to show you guys the kind
of main kind of problem we're solving
here with that second step is that
creating type for manually can take like
a super long time right
um basically right it's folks you know
going through every single slide
re-linking that Vimeo link it would take
forever it wouldn't even be possible
really for humans uh purposes also I'm
not sure if you guys ever used typeform
before but the it's a lot of drag and
drop click and stuff so if you have
really complicated logic or other
complicated needs in your type form you
really wouldn't be able to do it
feasibly at scale human uh for like
human creation basically so R and R
should connect I'm sorry positive
connect and ostriches are studio is a
great way to um
a great way to basically uh do automate
that kind of survey generation process
and basically the code behind this I'm
going to show actually a demo right now
if we can switch over to the screen
awesome
so uh this is the scoring uh story
scoring Hub here
um
zoom in a tiny bit okay
cool thank you nice
uh so I'm gonna go to this brand here uh
so this is a brand we work with and this
is a film that we made and we're
basically going to select uh some people
that we'd like to score the film
so I'm gonna pick myself
now I'm going to click my analytics
engineer
and my data scientist
and then this is all in Chinese I'm
going to press this button which is
going to send me a notification on slack
with a deadline for me to score this
film
okay
if I go slack you'll see and yes this is
Martin Scorsese photoshopped on top of
Thor the God of Thunder
um gave me a message saying hey we'd
like you to score this film here and so
saying I can accept or decline and it
has a link to the type form
which was just create with that API
with the film that I would like me to
watch on every single tab
so having a human actually go through
and add this link to every single tab
it's just not doable however with the
typeform API and just apis as a whole
you can create that process right there
um and again this is all as I showed you
in the earlier architecture diagram
um
there's really nothing else really
involved besides external apis and shiny
and r
um so but just to kind of circle the
loop a little bit I'm going to press
accept here
because I'm a good employee I'm gonna
accept it
um
I'm gonna get a message back saying
thanks I guess I click twice uh thanks
do you mark you down as accepting the
square request please complete the
survey as soon as you're able
which is great
um if we can Rachel go back to the
slides please
and so the code really behind what I
just did the posting the the
um the request to the typeform API and
creating that uh that survey was really
that code block there's a really
important one and it's just using your
favorite paste function either paste or
glue or whatever
um and basically just copying in
splicing that Vimeo film link with the
standard API request needed to generate
uh that survey on type form
yeah
all right now we're gonna move to the
third section
as soon as I get this to move
all right ah that was the score demo I
went a little early all right
um and then now we're gonna show you
guys creating deploying apis and plots
connect which uh I would put delightful
I think the way positive connect has
created the infrastructure for deploying
former apis it's click button easy
um I just want to share that kind of uh
Joy uh so first I'm going to go over
this kind of one use case of receiving
data
um just to kind of circle the loop on a
score thing so as you guys saw when I
press that accept button uh there's a
slack
um app function which I can show you on
this next slide
called interactivity so basically I put
our API here
uh with this hyper parameter of payload
here very similar to what I showed you
guys before this is something I have
deployed on positive connect and
basically when I clicked yes on that uh
that's that app in slack it basically
ran that uh API request with the payload
of he accepted right and then I just
have our code right in the background to
basically do all things need to update
the metadata in bigquery and then uh and
then also send that thank you message
back
um so that that's generally how it works
it's a very simple as you see down here
just a one function
um API uh basically one function eight
one request API
um what I do want to show you guys those
to kind of circle the loop but what that
means is after I ran that um oh I did it
again
um
after I ran gotta trust me Davis I
promise I'll trust you
this said score response status none but
now it says accepted uh because I press
the accept button on the app it went to
our API and then uh and updated bigquery
and it also um
and also uh send another request to the
API the slack API to send me a message
um
yeah so that's the that's the main thing
here if we go back to the slides
foreign
ERS here all right but the main event
though is actually showing how to deploy
hey Davis these API is really cool can
you show me how to deploy and make one
uh and absolutely uh so this is see if I
if I literally did nothing it would have
worked out absolutely perfectly
um
fantastic okay so you see here this is a
plumber R script for those who haven't
made one it's really easy to get started
in rstudio there's literally a plus
plumber API oh and when you click that
it'll just make a new one for you and
you'll get something that looks pretty
similar to this uh all you need to do is
load in your libraries that you would
use for this function so for me it's
plumber Loom lighter and then uh as I
mentioned before we're a gcp stack on
the back end so update our query
um and then here you just put your uh
different functions you want for your
API
um so for here I have two functions or
two requests so first is a get request
for my pizza rankings and it's just like
our function so you just write your
normal R function down here
um so here it's doesn't take any
parameters right I just want to give
this list of a data frame of pizza
rankings these also are all real pizza
places in Durham and this is this is my
official ranking so uh definitely highly
recommend pensions garage for pizza
um
and the second one which is much more
exciting is and by the way I want to
this is a really simple remedial example
but if you have external or internal
technical stakeholders who need data
that's in your data ecosystem
consistently this is a great way to
share it because I can change the source
of this I can make this a bigquery table
but as long as it's returning Pizza
rankings and restaurant and ranking here
uh in some format then
it's all good in my Downstream users are
not going to be impacted so that's the
real importance of an API is that if you
are sending people technical
stakeholders right because yeah the
business the business stakeholder isn't
gonna be able to use an API we're not
trying to solve that problem but
if you're working with other technical
teams that need data in your environment
this is the way to do it and it's really
easy I'll show you how how easy it is to
uh to deploy in just a couple seconds
and the other thing too is a fun
interactive thing I want to close out
today with uh which is uh I want to know
where everyone's coming in from today I
saw people from I think Brazil I saw
earlier uh Italy so obviously where
everyone's coming from both in the
United States and also out
um so I'm gonna ask you guys if you're
willing to submit an API request to kind
of tell me where you're coming from
um so this is the other kind of side too
is that you can get data into from other
technical stakeholders so
um I'll show you guys kind of the the
query so not left too far out but as you
see here I'm just doing a little bit of
checking here to make sure that folks
responses are expected and just
basically telling folks like please
characters please just two character
strings
um
yeah hey Igor how you doing uh it's like
Igor's comment earlier uh
uh then submit data frame rates I'm just
making a data frame uh and then I'm just
writing these are internal functions in
our internal package just right to our
bigquery environment
um and it's just uh that easy oh the
kind of a lot of answers submit it to
the API so if you want to see how it
looks locally you can press this play
API button and you can test it out
locally and you also just get all the
documentation right here so I can try
out this function here my pizza rankings
I can see here if you run this request
locally you'll get these this Json with
my pizza rankings
uh and then if you go down here I can
submit uh
I'm gonna submit one on behalf of my dog
uh his name's Theodore
about the last manager
uh North Carolina or the United States
uh and execute
and you'll see here you'll get a
response saying thanks for your response
uh and the database will be updated with
Theodore's response so okay that's great
news you got the API working locally it
was really easy but how do you get
deposit connect
just like you do anything else press the
publish button
that's going to do all its pack rat
package dependency Magic
and it's going to deploy on pause
connect
presto
and it's live so now folks if you want
to
um submit your um pull submissions I'd
love to and on top of it too I made a
little dashboard just in our our
markdown so I already submitted if I
refresh this we're going to see
uh
you're gonna see uh a second submission
that was just my submission yeah and you
know the raw response is writing you're
seeing me and my dog
um
I think my wife's watching I'm gonna be
clear I know how much I have a wife I'm
pretty sure she's watching so I'll make
sure she can submit uh I do not love the
dog more than the wife that is very true
uh Davis I want to make sure that I am
sharing with everybody too can you share
the link for me yes Yes actually if you
go back to the PowerPoint
okay
uh one second sorry
yeah if we go back I actually have the
code here and if uh someone could share
the actual code that'd be awesome
um
yep so if you do want the the less good
terminal example you can use that
terminal code up there so if you're a
Mac User just open up terminal uh if
you're cool I highly recommend using
warp as a terminal editor you can throw
it in there uh and then if R you just
run that R code down there and just swap
out the parameters with your information
and you'll be able to submit
um and then on the next page is the
pizza rankings probably less important
if you don't live in the Durham area
uh however they do exist
does this look okay for me sharing these
into the chat here we'll find out
if I wanted to make that uh Flex
dashboard
um
live I could have just made a
the um
in a shiny running shiny on Flex
dashboard and then that way it would be
actually pulling the bigquery every
single time instead of having to rerun
the report
uh but sometimes running static reports
is nicer it's easier to get together
um and Davis I was just curious so the
links that we shared
um where it's the terminal
and for R is there a way to share that
with somebody like what's the best way
to share those honest technical
uh honestly I wouldn't share with
someone no that's a great question okay
share it with someone lost technical
yeah
um this is kind of a fun example of what
you can do with apis just conceptually
however yeah like uh for the like
business stakeholders that I personally
work with I wouldn't have them working
in terminal or R
um I would be creating other ways like
shiny dashboards uh don't click on the
link it's you want to run the code
either in r or in curl
um
would you be able to show us how we do
sorry I'm like going off script here so
they all go good
um
ah thank you Aaron
um
all right yeah so
um
let me see if I can copy it from here if
it
is better uh can I comment in the chat
if you can't put it in the chat you can
put it in the private chat for us but
basically if I just take this and I open
up my Mac terminal for example
yeah that'll probably be a better idea
to have it on GitHub earlier
um
I wanted somebody to get awesome and
again whatever
um
yep so just
ah thank you Tony
yes attorney the link anyways uh
regardless it's the main the main point
though has anyone else submitted to see
um
a lot of folks from North Carolina
hello Ralph PK and Steve oh wait no
they're coming from California
interesting I wonder why it's not
showing over here
unless it screwed something up on that
graph
um thank you Ralph thank you Pico thank
you PK thank you Steve
yeah I think I just have some old data
or something
uh back there
um
anyways yeah uh if we could go back to
the deck there are a couple more just
considerations I just want to flag to
when making apis
um
uh if you want the pizza that's the
pizza but uh authentication is really
important apis you want to make sure
that the right people can have access to
your API both for asking for data but
also posting data
um so one thing is that when you create
packages for accessing apis and that
require authentication uh make sure to
never hard code your API keys because
someone could take them and impersonate
you and possibly do bad evil things so
store them in external files like on
your computer or something or in your
our profile as a global environment
variable this is a nice Safeguard and
also when you publish to get and things
like that then your keys won't go there
which is also good too uh for those who
don't know the HTTR package has also a
default place for you to put your
authorization authorization code in it's
like a hyper parameter called
authorization and standard format
generally is Bearer and then your API
key
uh also be careful about API public apis
uh so for this one it's all fun and
games and also not many people are
posting mostly uh due to me a little bit
um
but um
uh you don't want people uh uploading or
sending things to your environment that
you don't want so always try to do as
much error handling if you have a public
API uh then also if you can do a private
API do that uh positive connect makes it
really easy to create authenticated apis
all you have to do is just like on a
normal thing or document you publish on
positive connect switch the sharing
settings to all users login required and
then focusing just use an API key and
posit connect to authenticate so as an
example just to show folks
um
um if I wanted to make this one for
example
um
private I'll literally just switch it to
this press save go over here to API keys
and then make a new API key and share it
securely try not to do it via email
other these other tools as possible
um for folks to get access
so I think that's about it hopefully uh
these examples kind of get people more
excited about apis a really great way to
both share data take in data and just
kind of expand your data ecosystem
um and we'll see that we need to find at
least bar chart the bar charts needs to
be working
yeah I'm not sure what's going on there
well everyone's from the United States
so far but we know I saw some people
come from other fun places so
um great uh that's everything for right
now
thank you so much Davis I think
um with the example there it's because I
wasn't able to share it through YouTube
unfortunately it cuts off
the full length but we will figure out
some way maybe we could share that
through GitHub after with the recording
and put it and link it on the YouTube
recording but thank you so much after
let's say five years at positive I've
spoken with lots and lots of customers
and people are starting to explore using
plumber and a lot of people had asked
about ways other teams have used apis
and production so it's really awesome to
be able to learn about the work your
team is doing and see the real life
example so really appreciate you sharing
with us
I wanted to remind everybody that we
have lots of time for questions here so
I can show this slide a link on the
screen if you want to ask any questions
anonymously you can do so there let me
copy it over to
the chat as well there are a few that
I've seen on YouTube as well so you can
just ask here on YouTube
um I see one question that came over
from slido
from Eric was
how do you approach debugging
complicated unnesting of API results
when easy approaches do not work right
away
yeah great question
um
a couple so I try to read the document
if I'm really really stuck I try to read
the documentation as much as possible
just to sort of see kind of the thought
process going in
um another thing too is
um I really do think that the example I
showed with making a table and not
nesting there have been very few times
where I've run into like serious
problems with that and our internal
graphql API is really really complex and
really really nested so I think if you
follow that formula things should work
out pretty well
um just with the nesting wider and
longer
um and then the third thing too is uh if
you're using like a really common API
another solution kind of third door is
uh we use 5 train internally which is a
great way to just get your data into
your data ecosystem
um pretty easily uh just in a standard
format so
uh those that's kind of my response
great thank you
uh let me jump over to a YouTube
question I see
deepshat asked when combining shiny with
apis some API calls can take too long
have you come across that issue uh I've
come across with that just a little bit
um so there's a couple of things you can
do one depending on the API you're
paying
um page Nation pagination I'm not sure
how folks say some people say page
Nation some people say pagination tomato
uh passionation helps so if you can
break up that query into smaller queries
uh even if the code is less efficient so
even like a dumb map or a dumb for Loop
of just going through everything just so
it's smaller that'll help a lot too
um also if it is like a graphql API and
it does have built-in pagination
um that's going to both help if you have
internal users uh they're uh they're
kind of uh compute and also it's gonna
uh speed up your time as well
um and then as for the apis that I
deploy I have run into that a couple
times it was actually interesting during
the demo normally um the slack API when
it receives calls respects uh expects
calls coming in like I think a three
second or like less interval and only
comes around four or five seconds
um
and as a result it gives like a little
like warning like you're expecting a
response
um another thing you can do too is
increase the timeout
um time on your API so it's active more
often
um and so that's kind of more awake and
can take responses more frequently
however you will increase your compute
uh depending on where you're hosting
your positive connect instance
foreign
another question over on slido I think
was from PK
and I might need some help understanding
what bear tokens are but the question is
how has your experience been creating
apis that use authentication like bear
tokens I think bear bear uh I do like
the concept of bear tokens uh are they
I'm not sure maybe are they actually
called bear tokens in some circles I've
never heard that term before but uh but
yeah as I mentioned before with posix
it's really really easy
um outside of posit connect and with
positive connect as I mentioned before
it's just switching those sharing
settings and sharing like the PODS of
connect API key
um I even did that just a couple weeks
ago with an external technical
stakeholder and it could not have been
easier
um
ex outside of positive connect
to borrow the phrase It's a bear
um it's just I I never had that full
experience before but I just I can't
imagine like Docker laid on type of
authentication depending which platform
you're using the rules are much more
stricter much more complicated uh so I
would just say best of luck and
um
outside of that
thank you another anonymous question was
can we use or consume pins
within a polymer API absolutely yep uh
for uh generally we use bigquery for our
productionalized things however for kind
of quick and dirty apis I've made I
absolutely love to use pins yeah
awesome I'm going to share a link in the
chat too I think is a helpful example
with code as well um our Solutions
engineers
create this example of bike prediction
but it shows how pins and plumber and
shiny and vetiver are all tied together
too
that's another really cool thing that
we're actually we're not fully built yet
but we're also using vetiver and having
our modeling base hopefully off apis our
senior data scientist has been mostly
working on this where we're sending our
data to the API and getting the response
back and pushing to bigquery
that's great
uh let me jump back over to YouTube and
see there was a question from
last do you have any experience
consuming streaming data with websocket
protocol and r
a uh no I actually my experience of
streaming is pretty limited uh straight
up so uh no I do not have that
experience but best of luck hopefully
some other folks on the chat can help
you
yeah and I I didn't say that in the
beginning but if you have questions that
you have resources to share for things
that you can help with
um feel free to share in the chat as
well and share your own examples there
you see Ralph just asked when I query
apis it's often hundreds of calls in a
for Loop any ways to use cleaner code
than a big for Loop uh yeah anytime
you're using a for Loop you can probably
be doing a map
um they capped with maps sometimes
though is that if you use like a map
underscore like a certain format you
might get errors based off of your
response not matching that format so we
start with just a raw map as I kind of
showed you I use that map dfr for that
one example but you can just swap that
to a map for your kind of API call
function and that's a bit clearer than
just a for Loop
um but also I'm also a fairly big
proponent of not for Loop shaming like
nothing wrong with the for Loop if it
works it works for Loops are readable
but map is generally the cleaner
alternative
thank you
I'm going to throw a few more questions
at you here I see a few others coming in
you see Lisa had asked
and also said thank you so much Davis
this helped decomplicate things a bit
um how did you become more comfortable
with API documentation
uh so
um
that's a great question
a little bit of time so a little bit of
overtime in space I personally just find
projects where I really understand
the API like what's asking so I have a
personal project for my fantasy football
league where I'm pulling data from the
ESPN API to kind of get historical data
and modeling for um for a fancy Football
League that way where I see the
different objects I know generally what
the web UI is like and kind of generally
have a better understanding of this the
subject matter so I try not to get
bogged down as much with the parts I
don't know it's that's a really great
way to get more familiar and more
experience with apis
um so I'd say just again like all things
probably not the most helpful answer but
more experience and more practice and
just getting interested in just doing
side projects but
um but there are really tough ones out
there too
um API so I definitely don't act like
I'm the the API Paragon at all but
um but yeah the main thing is just I
also gotta say too doing it in our
studio and just being able to see the
data right there in the list else is a
really big help too so
awesome thank you I see a few there were
a few Anonymous or there was an
anonymous question a question in the
chat about posit connect pricing
I just concluded a link in the chat for
the posit connect page if you wanted to
schedule a call with our team it can be
different depending on the size of your
organization so if you work at a startup
or as large organization
um and so just wanted to include that
link if you want to chat with the team
but also if you're ever curious if your
company already has our tools I've seen
so many times where
there'll be like a small pocket of data
scientists over here and then a team
that has the tools on maybe in another
country of of that company so if you
ever are just curious and want to know
you can reach out to me directly as well
and I'm happy to connect you with your
account team too I'll put um my LinkedIn
and the chat here as well
also feel free to just schedule a call
with that link I put in the chat too
um
another
anonymous question I see let me just
copy it over to the screen here
and it was what options do you have for
API authentication besides posit connect
how do you integrate other Off Systems
with polymer
yeah I wish I wish I had a a better
answer
um
I know
um the way at least I would do it for
gcp is I would be looking at uh looking
at ways to get Google's oauth uh
integrated in there so I would just
start literally Googling like oauth
uh plumber
um
yeah but again that's the thing too I
mentioned before is
a part of the reason I'm completely
honest about the reason I do find this
process delightful is because of having
the positive connect API support
um so yeah I wish I had a better answer
um but I would start looking at Google
oauth if you're in gcp Amazon I'm not
sure what it is
um and you can also there's some really
dumb ways you can do it where uh like a
really dumb way to authenticate would to
be have off a parameter of your request
to be authentication and then um
probably not secure probably a terrible
idea but depending on your use case it
might be okay
um
thank you I um I can't remember if I
asked this question in here yet because
I didn't check off but uh one was Are
there specific packages to utilize apis
in shiny or just uh HTTR and shiny
reactivity
uh I I'm sure there are out there uh I
but I'll regardless I was able to
accomplish kind of everything kind of
showing this talk without those
um really hctr is the really fundamental
one
um there are probably other better ones
out there uh but
but possibly yep
thank you Davis uh let me just double
check over on slido I don't believe
there are any other questions that I
might oh
let's see
I don't see any other questions coming
through
but I'll give everybody a few more
seconds if there's anything I missed if
you want to put it back into the YouTube
chat as well
and I see somebody commented that my
video is fuzzy compared to Davis's side
by side so I will look into that I did
host the slides on restream and publish
them up so maybe that is what's
happening
with you a small shout out to Byron it
looks like an Ecuador uh so shout out to
Byron
are you still seeing results coming in
uh also Kelly in Oregon uh shout out to
Kelly
uh
shout out to uh Chaz
Florida
maybe Chase without any not sure uh yeah
but Byron coming from I guess that's
Ecuador I'm not quite sure that'll be my
guess
um well there actually was a question
before if you could share this code is
that something you're planning yeah uh
it's not gonna be the most useful
because I'm running to our bigquery
environment uh so uh I can switch swap
out with pins just so folks can use it
the problem with pins though is that you
have to like rip and replace the pin so
I don't want something weird happening
with multiple people using it oh yeah
but also I'll put this out with pins I
can share this then I can also
absolutely share the aviation code I
shared before
perfect yeah and I will share these
links that have been mentioned in the
chat and then the
um
code once Davis shares it with me with
the YouTube recording and so just wanted
to remind everybody that the YouTube
recording will be at the same link that
you watched it from today
but thank you all so much for spending
time with us today and spending with us
at all the meetups the past year I can't
believe this is the last one
of the year I'm wishing you all happy
holiday season and happy New Year we do
have our last data science hangout of
the Year this Thursday so there's one
more Community event so if you are
interested in joining us at JJ Lair
founder and CEO of posit will be joining
us this week and so
I will uh
put the link in the chat right now where
you can add that to your calendar too
thank you again Davis for an awesome
presentation
thank you so much for having us and hope
everyone has a great holiday season
bye everybody
thank you so much